it comes it always comes down to fear i
have a friend
um older guy
and this started a couple years ago and
he said you get your flu shot
and i said
no i've never gotten a shot my life and
he said well that's stupid
you should start getting a flu shot
okay and i went so you know i started
getting fired up and i said what do you
what do you
i'm stupid
because i i won't get a flu shot yeah i
mean you know i had the flu you don't
want it i said yeah you had it
because i see the way you it's what it
you got it wherever you got it people
get sick every september is another flu
and
fever every holiday flues and fevers
ago so then
we kept you know then it turned into
even back then this whole vax anti-vaxx
was already established a long time ago
and would amp up you guys all forget
they already remember measles measles
two years ago almost on the measles are
back wow who would have thought back
from the dead here come the measles get
your measles shot we'd have people going
coming in going you haven't got your
measles i said i'm not getting a stupid
measles oh god you're it's the same
thing to sit here and i told him he goes
uh
i can't believe you're uh not vaccinated
i went well let me ask you something so
if you're vaccinated
okay so if i take medicine it doesn't
work unless you take the medicine even
though you're not sick and i'm not sick
do you how did you destroy common sense
in humanity how did you take that little
piece out of the brain that makes no
sense whatsoever here you're shot boom
you're safe well
not unless
everyone else gets it
what
what
i'm just confused he keeps using this
word uh flu he keeps saying oh yeah dude
i don't know what that is you mean
there's no such thing as the thing that
disappeared last year look at the
numbers the flu doesn't exist anymore
yeah
now everything it's a miracle the flu
actually doesn't exist anymore which is
awesome
it's true though and the thing is like
that's the other problem is you know i
if you would have told me i would say
like 10 years ago that this would happen
and go bro look people aren't that
stupid people aren't that dumb but now
like the shocking part to me isn't that
the government did shady things because
they always do shady things right the
shocking part to me is how many people
immediately just said yes master yes
you're right you are right i can't go to
a dave matthews concert if i don't have
three shots that makes total sense thank
god i'd rather get covered
but
that's just mean
and not just the government but how much
we bowed to big pharma who i thought we
hated like a year ago right like didn't
we all hate the pharmaceutical companies
two years ago weren't they like evil
[ __ ] money grubbing price gouging
scumbags and then all of a sudden it was
like oh no you guys are all heroes all
right i'll take whatever experience i
don't know this is a this is a drug lord
battle it's been going on since the
beginning of time the only difference is
they're so powerful they've taken over
the entire world and their drugs are
legalized
so
you know they figured it out we're not
going to sell them on the streets we're
going to send our our gangs to
med school and then we're going to take
over the med schools and we're going to
train over there and then we're going to
put all the doctors in one and then you
can't question anything because it all
comes from the guys now we own it all
and control it all oh wow make sure you
keep wearing the the lab coats everyone
believes you but that is this has been
going on they started drugging your kids
when they gave you adh pills adh
your child has a condition i've never
seen so many conditions in my life over
the last 15 20 years it's um
but listen
at the end of the day um
we could talk about all we want
um
it doesn't bring out any positivity and
i keep telling everyone well now why
[Music]
[Music]
you